Bonjour à tous,
aujourd'hui on va parler de la plus belle expérience de toute la physique.
En tout cas, celle qui a été élue comme telle en 2002 par les lecteurs du magazine Physics World.
Il s'agit d'une expérience spectaculaire emblématique de la mécanique quantique.
Une expérience que le grand physicien Richard Feynman utilisait déjà dans les années 60, de façon fameuse, pour enseigner son célèbre cours sur le sujet.
Et pourtant cette expérience, personne ne l'a jamais vraiment faite, jusqu'à il y a seulement quelques années...
Pour comprendre l'histoire de cette expérience, il faut remonter à la fin du XVIIe siècle.
A cette époque, 2 grands physiciens s'affrontaient pour comprendre la nature profonde de la lumière.
Le célèbre Isaac Newton était persuadé que la lumière était faite de corpuscules, de particules,
tandis que le néerlandais Christian Huygens, lui était convaincu que la lumière était une onde.
La question n'a en fait pas été tranchée de leur vivant, et beaucoup pensaient que c'était Newton qui avait raison parce que... bah Newton quoi.
Jusqu'en 1801, presque un siècle plus tard, où un autre physicien, Thomas Young, a mis fin au débat avec une expérience faisant intervenir
une double fente. Et pour comprendre pourquoi une double fente, on va commencer par des choses simples.
Imaginez une planche de bois dans laquelle on a percé une fente de quelques centimètres,
un peu comme une meurtrière si vous voulez, et derrière laquelle se trouve un mur.
Et supposez que vous tiriez sur la planche avec une mitraillette.
Alors comme vous savez pas très très bien viser, un certain nombre des balles se retrouve arrêté par la planche
tandis que le reste passe par la fente, et va se loger dans le mur.
Et sur ce mur, l'impact de l'ensemble des balles forme une tache allongée qui reproduit à peu près la forme de la fente. Normal.
Maintenant imaginez que dans la planche il y ait deux fentes, assez proches l'une de l'autre, et que vous tiriez dans leur direction.
Eh bien il va se passer la même chose, sauf que les impacts formeront cette fois deux taches allongés côte à côte
la tache de gauche correspondant aux balles passées par la fente de gauche, et pareil à droite.
Alors tout ça vous semble certainement parfaitement évident, mais maintenant
imaginons que l'on fasse la même expérience, non pas avec des balles de mitraillette, mais avec des ondes.
Autour de nous il existe plein d'ondes : les ondes radios, les ondes sonores, les micro ondes, etc...
mais elles ne sont pas forcément simples à se représenter. Alors on va prendre un autre type d'onde, que tout le monde connaît : les vagues.
Pour être honnête sur le plan physique les vagues ne sont pas les ondes les plus simples qui soient
mais pour notre visualisation ça va suffire.
Imaginez donc une série de vagues qui se propagent à la surface de l'eau.
Pour étudier ce phénomène de façon contrôlée, j'ai utilisé un petit montage expérimental qu'on appelle une cuve à ondes.
Une cuve à ondes c'est une sorte de bac à fond transparent
dans lequel on peut verser une faible épaisseur d'eau, et qui est muni d'un système d'éclairage
stroboscopique et d'un miroir, de façon à pouvoir visualiser les ondes sur un écran.
Sauf qu'ici, plutôt que de faire des vagues à la main, j'ai utilisé une petite barre qui vibre et qui crée des ondes en surface
et j'ai éteint la lumière ambiante pour mieux voir l'écran. Voilà ce qu'on observe.
Alors comme je suis pas super bon pour faire des expériences, pour compléter j'ai fait aussi une petite simulation numérique.
Cette simulation elle permet de calculer la propagation des vagues, et représente le même genre de choses : ici c'est une vue de dessus
quand c'est sombre c'est un creux de la vague et quand c'est clair c'est un sommet.
Bon maintenant la question c'est : qu'est ce qui se passe si je balance une onde de ce genre à travers une fente ?
Voici une forme placée sur le chemin de mon onde. Intuitivement on pourrait penser qu'il va se passer ça.
Et ben essayons avec la cuve à ondes, j'ai placé un obstacle avec une petite fente au milieu...
... et voilà ce qu'on observe.
On constate que derrière la fente, l'onde devient circulaire.
Et on retrouve évidemment la même chose, en plus visible, si on fait tourner ma simulation.
Ça c'est un phénomène qu'on appelle la diffraction.
On peut parfois l'observer avec des vraies vagues sur des photos Google Earth de bord de mer, comme ici c'est le port d'Alexandrie.
Bien maintenant refaisons la même expérience, mais cette fois avec 2 fentes. Dans la cuve à ondes j'ai placé un obstacle avec deux ouvertures
Et, comme on pouvait s'y attendre, on observe deux ondes circulaires, qui émergent de chacune des fentes.
... sauf que dans la zone où les ondes se rencontrent, il se passe un truc étrange.
Ça se voit mieux sur la simulation, regardez.
Imaginez que je me trouve ici, sur l'axe central. A cet endroit les deux ondes que je reçois s'ajoutent.
Les deux sommets se cumulent, et forment un sommet plus élevé, et inversement, juste après les deux creux coïncident, et ainsi de suite
Globalement, en ce point, on a des vagues dont l'amplitude est doublée.
Mais si je me déplace un tout petit peu, ici, vous voyez que je suis plus près d'une fente que de l'autre
et les deux ondes arrivent donc décalées l'une par rapport à l'autre.
Et à cet endroit, le creux de la première onde coïncide avec le sommet de la seconde, et réciproquement.
Et du coup, les deux ondes se compensent exactement.
Vous voyez que pile à cet endroit, là, ça ne bouge pas : l'amplitude des vagues est nulle. En fait y'a pas de vague.
Et on retrouve bien ça dans l'expérience de la cuve, regardez
dans ces zones, ici, on n'a pas de vagues : les deux ondes se compensent.
Tout ça forme un phénomène qu'on appelle des interférences
et quand on regarde de plus près, on voit qu'on a une succession de zones où les ondes s'ajoutent
et où au contraire elle se compensent.
Si on s'amuse à tracer l'amplitude des vagues en fonction de la position, ici, on a une oscillation de ce genre
Cette figure d'interférences, qu'on obtient quand une onde rencontre une double fente, est donc très différent de ce qu'on avait avec des balles de mitraillette
où on avait deux zones bien localisées. Les interférences sont un phénomène typique des ondes.
Alors comme je vous disais au début, en 1801, Thomas Young s'intéresse donc au débat sur la nature de la lumière
"onde ou particules", et il se demande ce qui se passe quand on fait justement passer de la lumière par une double fente.
Alors à l'époque il l'avait fait avec la lumière du soleil, mais c'est une expérience qu'on peut refaire plus facilement aujourd'hui avec un laser.
Ici j'ai placé un laser rouge, dont on a élargi un peu le faisceau...
... et sa lumière arrive sur ces deux minuscules fentes, qui sont très rapprochées : le tout fait moins d'un millimètre de large.
Et voici ce que j'ai obtenu sur l'écran situé un peu plus loin :
des belles interférences.
On n'a pas du tout deux taches comme on aurait avec des projectiles, mais quelque chose de typique d'une onde.
Et c'est avec une expérience de ce genre que Young conclut que la lumière est donc une onde, et que c'est Huygens qui avait raison.
... enfin, provisoirement. A ce stade de la vidéo vous avez peut-être l'impression que vous être fait avoir :
je vous ai promis de la mécanique quantique, et pour l'instant je vous parle de vagues, et de querelles de physiciens du 17e.
Alors, rentrons dans le vif du sujet : à votre avis, qu'est ce qui se passe si on fait l'expérience de la double fente avec des électrons ?
La première chose qu'il faut dire c'est qu'on sait faire l'équivalent d'une mitraillette à électrons : un canon à électrons. C'est le principe du tube cathodique.
Vous savez, celui qu'on trouve dans les vieilles télés dont les écrans sont pas plats du tout.
Pour faire un tube cathodique, on prend un filament -par exemple de tungstène- qu'on chauffe avec un courant électrique, comme dans une ampoule.
Le filament va alors émettre des électrons.
Avec un voltage élevé, on peut alors créer un champ électrique qui va accélérer ces électrons, et les envoyer dans une certaine direction.
(et on prend soin de mettre tout ça sous vide, dans un tube)
Pour voir les électrons, on peut placer une substance phosphorescente à l'extrémité du tube, et on verra alors des tâches lumineuses
laissées par les électrons qui l'atteignent.
C'est le principe de l'écran cathodique, et c'est d'ailleurs avec une expérience de ce genre qu'un autre physicien,
Thompson, a pu montrer à la fin du 19ème que les électrons étaient bien des particules, et qu'on pouvait dévier leurs trajectoires.
Comme ça il a même appris des choses sur leur masse et leur charge électrique.
Bien donc on sait faire un canon à électrons : et ben balançons ça sur une double fente, en mettant derrière un écran
phosphorescent, et voyons ce qu'on obtient. Et bien si vous faisiez cette expérience, voilà ce que vous observeriez.
C'est bizarre non ? On n'a pas du tout deux taches, comme avec des balles de mitraillette, mais une alternance de bandes noires et blanches
qui rappellent quand même furieusement des interférences.
Qu'est ce qui se passe, pourquoi est ce qu'on n'obtient pas la même chose qu'avec les balles de mitraillette, c'est-à-dire deux tâches ?
Un truc qu'on peut se dire pour essayer de l'expliquer, c'est qu'on n'est quand même pas tout à fait dans la même situation :
Déjà, la mitraillette tire les balles une par une
Alors que là il y a certainement une quantité énorme d'électrons qui sont émis tous en même temps.
Et puis, les balles, une fois en vol, on sait qu'elles s'influencent pas les unes les autres,
par contre les électrons, ce sont des particules chargées, donc on pourrait imaginer qu'ils interagissent entre eux au cours de leur trajectoire.
Par exemple qu'ils se repoussent par endroits, ou bien qu'il existe une force qui nous échappe qui les dévie, pour provoquer cette figure, pourquoi pas.
Pour tester ça on peut faire une chose : c'est baisser la fréquence de tir du canon à électrons pour envoyer les électrons 1 par 1
De telle sorte qu'un électron ait le temps d'arriver sur l'écran avant que le suivant soit émis.
Et là il se passe un truc de malade : si on tire les électrons 1 par 1, on constate effectivement que chacun provoque une tâche lumineuse sur l'écran.
Sauf que peu à peu... on voit se construire une alternance de bandes claires et sombres.
Les électrons, 1 par 1, viennent former des interférences
En tirant comme ça les électrons individuellement, on peut difficilement soutenir qu'ils s'influencent entre eux pour venir former des interférences.
Pour essayer d'y voir plus clair, un truc qu'on peut faire c'est d'essayer de comprendre, sur cette figure,
quels sont les électrons passés par la première fente et par la seconde.
Est-ce qu'à droite ce sont les électrons passés par la fente de droite et à gauche par la fente de gauche ?
Pour ça il y a une façon simple de procéder : il suffit de boucher
alternativement une fente, puis l'autre, pour obtenir les deux parties de la figure.
Si on n'ouvre qu'une seule des deux fentes, voilà le genre de figure qu'on obtient
Pas d'interférence, mais une seule tache assez étalée
Et pareil si c'est l'autre fente qu'on ouvre.
Mais du coup on a un truc complètement inattendu là,
la figure avec les deux fentes ouverte n'est pas égale à celle qu'on obtient en additionnant les deux figures obtenues avec une seule fente.
Pour comprendre à quel point ce résultat est anormal, revenons au cas de la mitraillette :
quand je tire sur les deux fentes, chaque balle passe soit par une fente soit par l'autre.
Quand une balle passe par la fente 1, que la fente 2 soit bouchée ou pas, ça ne change rien, et réciproquement,
donc la figure qu'on obtient quand les deux fentes sont ouvertes est bien la somme des deux figures obtenue avec une seule fente.
Et bien dans le cas des électrons ça n'est pas le cas, et ça semble indiquer que quand un électron passe par la fente 1
et bien son comportement va dépendre du fait que la fente 2 soit ouverte ou pas.
Et l'effet est vraiment critique puisqu'on a carrément des zones de l'image qui, quand on débouche la fente 2,
vont devenir plus sombres, c'est à dire recevoir moins d'électrons que quand elle était fermée.
Je rappelle que les électrons arrivent 1 par 1 :
Ça veut dire que le point d'arrivée de chaque électron dépend de l'état des deux fentes.
Comment on peut expliquer ça ?
On pourrait dire, à la limite, que quand un électron passe par une fente, et ben il est influencé par l'état de l'autre fente
ça veut dire qu'il "sait" ou qu'il "sent" si elle est ouverte ou fermée.
Une façon encore plus imagée de se le représenter, c'est de dire carrément que quand les deux fentes sont ouvertes
les électrons passent tous par les deux fentes à la fois.
Après tout, c'est ce que fait une onde,
et c'est ça qui explique qu'on obtienne des interférences.
Bah oui, sauf qu'un électron c'est pas une onde, c'est une particule.
Et une particule qui passe par deux chemins à la fois, c'est quand même un peu difficile à avaler.
Pour lever le mystère, on peut peut-être laisser les deux fentes ouvertes, pour avoir des interférences,
mais placer un détecteur, qui permette de savoir quand même par quelle fente est passé chaque électron.
Pour ça, Richard Feynman a proposé d'utiliser le fait que les électrons diffusent la lumière :
c'est à dire que si je balance une lumière intense sur un électron, et bien il va renvoyer une partie de cette lumière dans toutes les directions
Dans notre montage, on peut du coup imaginer mettre une grosse source lumineuse juste après les deux fentes, et des détecteurs de lumière à côté.
Ça permettrait alors, chaque fois qu'un électron voyage, de le faire briller, et donc de révéler par quel fente il est passé.
Et bien si on ajoute effectivement un tel système de détection, nouvelle surprise :
la figure d'interférences disparaît. On a bien les deux fentes ouvertes, mais on se retrouve seulement avec une grosse tâche
qui en fait, est la somme des deux qu'on a quand on n'ouvre qu'une seule fente.
Grâce aux détecteurs, on arrive effectivement à dire par quelle fente est passé chaque électron, mais du coup il n'y a plus d'interférences.
Il est impossible d'avoir à la fois les interférences et de savoir par quel fente passe chaque électron.
C'est l'un ou l'autre.
Donc non seulement les électrons semblent passer par les deux fentes à la fois,
mais en plus si on essaie de savoir par quelle fente ils passent effectivement, leurs comportements changent.
Ces expériences peuvent vous paraître un peu folles, et d'ailleurs c'est le cas, c'est pour ça qu'elles fascinent autant les physiciens.
Aujourd'hui on arrive à les interpréter dans le cadre du formalisme de la mécanique quantique.
Alors je vais évidemment pas tout vous détailler, mais je vais essayer de vous en donner un aperçu.
De façon générale, la mécanique quantique nous dit que suivant la situation
les objets quantiques peuvent se comporter comme des ondes ou comme des particules, et parfois les deux dans la même expérience.
C'est le principe de la dualité onde-corpuscule.
Dans notre expérience, l'électron voyage initialement comme une onde, de façon délocalisée, et quand il traverse l'obstacle
il est donc influencé par les deux fentes,
et l'onde produit des interférences.
Mais quand l'électron arrive sur l'écran, ce dernier fonctionne comme un détecteur de position, qui en quelque sorte
le "force" à se localiser dans une position précise, et donc on a un point lumineux qui apparaît sur l'écran.
L'endroit exact où apparaît ce point est aléatoire, mais il obéit à une règle :
l'électron va se localiser préférentiellement dans les zones où l'onde est forte.
Cette onde dont on parle est en fait une onde de probabilité de présence,
elle représente la probabilité de détecter l'électron à tel ou tel endroit.
Et c'est pour ça qu'on a une figure d'interférence sur l'écran, les bandes lumineuses
correspondent aux zones où la probabilité de présence est élevée, et où beaucoup d'électrons vont se localiser
tandis que les bandes sombres sont les zones de probabilité de présence plus faible.
Puisque l'électron voyage comme une onde et se localise en une particule seulement une fois sur l'écran,
ça traduit la nature fondamentalement probabiliste de la mécanique quantique.
Ça n'est pas comme si chaque électron avait un trajet qui nous apparaisse aléatoire du fait de notre ignorance,
mais que dans le fond il ait quand même suivi une trajectoire bien déterminée, non, non, il passe par les deux fentes à la fois.
Et on a vu que si on refuse cette idée, et qu'on met un détecteur pour essayer de révéler sa trajectoire,
on détruit les interférences,
car on le force aussi à se localiser, et à "devenir une particule" si vous voulez.
A ce moment-là il "choisit" donc, un peu aléatoirement, la fente par laquelle il est passé.
C'est bizarre non ?
Cette expérience est vraiment fabuleuse car elle nous montre les ingrédients essentiels de la mécanique quantique.
Il y a la dualité onde-corpuscule bien sûr,
mais aussi le fait que la mécanique quantique est fondamentalement probabiliste.
Et enfin cette expérience nous montre qu'on ne peut pas observer certains phénomènes,
comme par exemple la position d'une particule,
sans perturber l'expérience de façon dramatique.
J'espère que vous comprenez maintenant pourquoi cette version de l'expérience de la double fente, où on envoie les électrons 1 par 1,
est considérée comme la plus belle de toute la physique par beaucoup.
Et pourtant, je vous le disais en intro, bien qu'elle soit très populaire depuis les années 60
cette expérience n'a vraiment été réalisée sous cette forme-là qu'en 2013.
Pour ceux que ça intéresse, je donne des détails dans le billet de blog qui accompagne la vidéo.
Merci d'avoir suivi la vidéo, si vous l'avez apprécié abonnez-vous, la cloche tout ça,
un merci tout particulier à Arnaud qui m'a accueilli, et vraiment bien aidé pour les expériences,
et j'espère qu'on remettra ça.
Comme d'habitude l'actu de la chaîne c'est facebook et twitter, et on se retrouve très bientôt pour des nouvelles vidéos